bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur ert france ce matin alors
depuis mardi la france a été à la
recherche de ces djihadistes qui ont
sévi au bénin des attaques non
revendiquées mais qui porte justement la
signature des terroristes est ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui que le djihadisme
est en train de s'étendre dans le golfe
de guinée
en effet c'est la confirmation de
laquelle tu que le djihadisme puisse
contaminer de légion du golfe de guinée
cette confirmation un
ami ni la france à y agir parce que si
la france ne réagit pas la france
perdrait totalement sa crédibilité et sa
légitimité sa présence dans cette région
qui est justifié listons par la ligue
contre ce fléau aujourd'hui cette
réaction rapide de bakkal qu'une
confirmation aussi de l'intention de la
france de marquer peut-être son probable
départ du mali que la france continuera
à combattre le terrorisme dans les
autres pays du champ et que la france
reste la france possède iniquité l'a pas
le seul à continuer le combat donc
ça veut dire une confirmation que le de
dia 10 à 1,32 chacun de cette région du
golfe de guinée qui a été acquis des
parts ni relativement égaux la france
attend film et a filmé les encore
présent dire qu'on continuera à
combattre le terrorisme malgré son
départ du mali alors justement ces
terroristes ils ont été tuées au burkina
faso on le rappelle un pays frontalier
du bénin est ce qu'aujourd'hui le
burkina faso on peut dire que c'est le
maillon faible du sahel qui n'est pas
justement à ses protégés et vers là où
les terroristes fuient
en effet deux blocs une arête de la
frontière sud des fonds contre le
décompte de tourisme aujourd'hui le
bénin bénigne la frontière sud des
dégâts l'école de tourisme donc le bic
ne manque peut-être cela ce que le mali
a été à l'époque et que par contre la
réaction de la france et la manière dont
a été menée cette réaction vis-à-vis de
cette attaque en concertation avec les
autorités burkinabè et des autorités
béninoises cela montre que la part aussi
à charger la poche de la lutte contre le
terrorisme pas en décidant
unilatéralement un contrôle commande à
l'époque uniquement par les français
cette façon de travailler de façon
ouverte
et collégial
de réussir l'un ou
les tables qui n'a bien échoué pendant
toutes ces années peut-être peut-être la
frontière comme dans l'autre
alors on l'a dit la france est présente
au sahel depuis maintenant neuf ans même
s'il n'est peut-être qu'une partie des
troupes va partir du mali
et on a du mal quand même à contenir
justement cette violence ces groupes
djihadistes qui sévissent quels sont les
facteurs qui favorisent aujourd'hui
l'extension du jihadisme notamment vers
paire loeb le burkina faso
s'est départi ce qu il me l'avait bien
dit que les réponses à la lutte contre
le djihadisme était de l'époque ont su
transposer et appliquée uniquement seul
aspect militaire beaucoup des réalités
locales ont été ignorés beaucoup de
cause la chance de l'état à la probité
la la pauvreté mauvaise gouvernance
c'est terminé d'ailleurs ajusté vie les
coups d'état qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans
cette sous-région les militaires juste
rien de l'état n'a pas de l'état
l'absence de moyens et aussi
l'implication des communautés des chefs
traditionnels puisque quand on regarde
un les foyers n'est pas de sitôt la
liste aujourd'hui ils ont attaqué deux
le bénissons rentrer et excédé les
bracelets plus de bonheur ou le niger
d'autres c'est un convoi céder de lui
roule et russes de cette fois devant des
communautés qu'ils soient des
communautés ethniques des communautés
régionales ur des communautés
religieuses donc la réponse aussi doit
venir de sept de ses côtés à
l'implication et la prise en compte des
avis mais ces leaders traditionnels
religieux dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et escalade et aussi en p67
genius de pouvoir aller gratter police
l'a donc la réponse est très important
en
matière de gouvernance politique
également on voit que la situation a
beaucoup changé cette année jours en
afrique de l'ouest pas mal de coup
d'état est ce que cela aura un impact
justement sur cette lutte antiterroriste
si les militaires que le pouvoir parce
que le les pouvoirs civils on n'est pas
assez de vie eh bien c'est raté de la
kabylité s'en va dire que le déclic est
réussi
s'il a raison c'est qu'il était utile à
plus de pouvoirs et bien tenir réponse
résultat les autres c'est ça
résultat dans ce domaine ne les attend
pas à la bonne gouvernance dans les
transports caution 10 voir qu'ils ont
été renversés les civils qu'ils soient
au mali au bénin ou même qu'ils nient
c'était l'aspect sécuritaire comme
maintenant il dévisse même beau diable
tout le monde justifie
eh bien ils ont l'obligation de résultat
signalé pas à répondre à cette
obligation de résultat eh bien ils n'ont
aucune légitimité aucune crédibilité
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions a déclaré mme gakuba
koundougou me je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé au groupe afrique de
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe